[Music]
welcome I'm I'm hoping the people that
in the lobby can hear me - pretty
amazing to have this kind of turnout for
archival footage I'm excited by that
never knew there was quite this many
archivist geeks out there we got a lot
in the front row it turns out the next
talk is Saul Griffith and his talk is
called climate change recalculated Saul
has some of the most amazing numbers on
our coming climate challenge in the next
century that I've ever seen and I've
just been looking at them in the early
chapters of Stuart's book and I am
Alexander as the director of long now
foundation by the way who's normally
here as Stewart Stewart is on book
deadline he's going to be sifting
questions instead of giving them today
back in 1998 we as long now foundation
did our very first conference and it was
called time and bits managing digital
continuity and in in 1998 that was a
pretty novel concept that people were
really archiving digital stuff and
Brewster Kahle who's actually here in
the audience set from the Internet
Archive was was in attendance and one of
the few people doing really good work at
the time and we realized a couple things
there were two main ideas came out of
that one of them was spawned also by
Brewster and that was to start our
Rosetta project with a very slow form of
archiving that's done with itching into
micro micro etching into metal that
could last for thousands of years but
the other one is one that's that's now
been coined by Kevin Kelly as move itch
and that's the idea of accessibility and
movability in digital data and it's this
accessibility thing that was actually
very different that then all the other
archivists were doing in the world
generally archivists were hoarders
historically they were not givers and we
started realizing in a lot that this was
the right way with digital materials and
we started aligning ourselves with
people like Mike Keller at the
at the Stanford library brewster kahle
at the Internet Archive and we
eventually met Rick Prelinger through
Brewster who was archiving digitally
some of the most difficult things to
archive there was digitally and that's
film and tonight he's going to show you
some of that amazingness thank you
well thank you so much for coming and
thank you especially intrepid people
outside can I have a little bit a little
bit less light is that at all possible
tiny bit less light I guess I can deal
so so what to think about as we look at
lost landscapes tonight here's just a
few quick thoughts in 1982 I got a job
doing research on a documentary feature
and along the way I discovered that the
u.s. was the media richest nation in the
world we throw out more media than most
countries ever produce I got interested
in films that had evidentiary value and
I started to collect them these were
educational films made to train to
educate often to miss educate industrial
films filled with imagery of people
working in history of technology and
advertising films that were about
promoting products causes particular
ways of thinking over the next 20 years
I collected films and raw footage I
started a stock footage business to fund
these the pace of acquisitions which
grew to about a hundred and fifty
thousand cans mostly stored in a cool
room in the meat market in Manhattan
it's very very hard to take good care of
heavy temperamental physical objects and
I started to get worried about the
future of the collection both Danny
Hillis and Howard Besser suggested I
meet up with Brewster Kahle in the first
30 seconds Brewster said wow we were
just talking at Thursday night dinner
wondering where we could find a film
archive to put online for free want to
put your archives online for free this
was 1999 and I just moved out here from
New York and I thought information
wanted to be expensive and so I
stuttered my way through that
conversation but soon I started to think
this might be worth trying and we began
to build a free online moving image
archive which now has over 200,000 mm
excuse me 2,000 films and is still
growing you can download project reuse
rillette it and resell the online movies
and we've been able to tug this rather
odd body of media into the mains
soon afterwards our film collection was
acquired by the Library of Congress and
then in 2004 Megan and I opened our
library and we filled the shelves with
books periodicals print ephemera scenes
and maps it's open to the public many of
you have been many of you have shelved
Thank You its appropriation friendly you
can come and scan material to use in
your own work if you haven't visited
we'd love to see you all the great
things that can happen when you join the
gift economy began to happen for us and
now I guess we're hoping we can gift our
way through the depression above all I
got interested in home movies so how
movies are the great exception to what
we usually think of as film they
typically show scenes of everyday life
they're made by unknown authors and
above all their personal expression
they're not commercial or corporate
expression over time there were billions
and billions of feet of all movies 1
million feet of 16 millimeter equals
something less than 700 hours if it's
shot silent less than 500 hours if it's
shot sound 700 hours is probably a few
days of lab output back in the day but
each reel is unique even if many of them
show similar ceremonies and similar
rituals most reels were never duplicated
and only one original exists so these
are more than evidence these are also
unique artifacts some of them have been
handed down but many of not and the
world is filled with other people's home
movies many of which contain fascinating
evidence enigmatic imagery things you
can't see elsewhere and many of which
can be vehicles for complex historical
insights Kodachrome for example a
Kodachrome film is a relatively stable
record of people places and activities
at a given time and it's typically in
beautiful color tonight you'll see video
transfers from Kodachrome films from
1939 40 41 that look as if they could
have been shot yesterday except for the
noise that the video introduces the
density of detail and the dramatic
presence of the material trumps still
photos beat up film prints and
any digital videos but what I'm gonna be
showing tonight isn't just home movies
it's also outs outtakes from industrial
and sponsored films and bits and pieces
of newsreel footage these are mostly
ephemeral records they were not made for
posterity Industrial and sponsored films
were typically made for specific reasons
at specific times and home movies were
of course made to be shown within
individual families so most survived by
accident moving images don't just
document histories in fact they make
histories accessible but first they
themselves have to be accessible and
aside from what studios distribute and
pirates seed there's relatively little
public access to archival moving images
aside from a few courageous DVD projects
like National Film Preservation
Foundation but the reasons are copyright
worries and a culture of art of archival
enclosure this is a big big problem
today we can document daily life with
almost infinite granularity in fact
we're approaching that bore hazy and the
one-to-one correspondence between the
world and the map but documentation of
the past is of a different class it's
finite it's often precious we wish we
had more
I've often I've often played out mental
scenarios that involve going back in
time with a high-res camera and plenty
of batteries and I'm sure many of you
have too arguably we have an abundant
present and a parsimonious past but it
only takes a few years before an
abundance of documentation decays into a
mess of records that are hard to parse
and hard to search it's going to be more
expensive to select than it is to
collect this is certainly my life story
we can add we can add coherence by
curating and contextualizing records if
anyone can find the time and we'll do
some of that in about five minutes
most archival functions are likely to be
fulfilled by machines except for working
with historical material which i think
is going to continue to be an artisanal
activity but back to the first question
so what's the use of all this getting
together on a Friday night to watch old
clips and
talk back to the screen seems fairly
innocuous it's unlikely to matter very
much in the long term and how important
how valuable can old archival clips
really be well there's many many
interesting things you could do with
archival footage but people don't do
very much with it except to sell stock
shots stock shots are really expensive
prices have no relation to actual costs
in my opinion in fact most archives are
tremendously overvalued only a small
minority of images very specific memes
mesh well with a commercial media matrix
and just a few percent of archival
holdings ever generate any income
I see image archives actually fitting in
another way I think we've started
building a digital model of the universe
as we know it it's a model that
aggregates newly acquired imagery which
comes in very quickly with archival
images which come in more slowly because
they're analog and because there's you
know latency built into the way that
archives work we've seen this begin to
happen with maps and with still pictures
and it'll be this that gives archives a
chance to come into their own
not more cable TV channels or more video
on demand so we're starting to see a lot
more image geo-tagging geo-tagging means
attaching spatial coordinates to an
image so not just where it was shot but
what it sees you might have tags like
location altitude angle of viewing range
and knitting tags and images together as
one tiny incremental step towards the
creation of what you could call a four
dimensional model of the world that
shows the development of place over time
there's lots of obvious uses for a model
like this many of you have probably
thought about it history could emerge
from its hiding places in the landscape
and history could become visible
infrastructure what isn't so obvious is
how the existence of a 4d model will
affect both the raw data and the
landscapes that it represents it might
be more than just another excursion into
the symbolic domain so a model of the
world past present and future will be
valuable even throwaway images will gain
value
as they become part of a system that has
predictive power in fact any image that
can help a human or a machine to
extrapolate the future will be invested
with new importance archival images such
as aerial photos already assist in
predicting the modes and the directions
and the velocity of human build-out and
infrastructure but there's going to be
consequence in smaller details as well
so here are our living room windows as
they showed up in Google Street View
earlier this year what's that in the
left-hand window it's a film reel and
the arm of a projector
that's almost revealing enough to be
planned but it wasn't and here's the
refreshed view as of yesterday note the
difference from the first to the second
the projectors gone my own case is
unimportant because I don't think that
really means very much but anyone
watching the sum of small changes on my
block this way and through other models
would be able to derive a lot of
actionable information especially if
these changes were crunched along with
all the other changes seen in the city
how the Richmond District grew out
starting in the 20s may help to predict
how it's going to develop into 20 20s I
think there's gonna be great contention
over these these models in the same way
that Barbra Streisand fought the aerial
photographers and we're shooting the
entire California coast and wanted to
shoot her property - from the air who
will own the 3d models do they
constitute fair use of copyrighted
structures you know you can copyright
buildings now if I control
representations of my own space and the
present does that mean that I control it
in the past or in the future
neighborhoods towns entire countries may
pull out of 3d modeling as they've tried
to pull out of Street View they may not
want to be used for marketing they may
not want police to know what their place
looks like and I'm going to be
interested to see what happens to
archival images when they're all geo
tagged and embedded into a 4d model as
with as with media like online books
searchable video and commercial
databases the social price of the added
value might be increased in closure so
ironically we may have to fight to free
images just because we finally figured
out ways to use them
so the past does not pass a its prologue
what seems completely antiquated may in
fact be predictive so maybe the idea of
lost landscapes is a misnomer we're not
just getting together to watch old
footage we're a focus group on what the
future of San Francisco could be if we
squint hard we might see the kernel of
the future and the mind youth details of
the past so we are not here for an art
film screening please shout out when you
recognize something talk back to the
screen this is interactive cinema and
now I'm going to present to you lost
landscape three
[Applause]
[Applause]
my conrick yeah this is John summers
home movies he's flying into San
Francisco Airport
South San Francisco maybe same places
now
1941 August
[Music]
the airport bar
this is 1938 we're messing with time
here 1962
interstate 280 unfinished
still unfinished 1962 thereabouts
yeah might have been on a Sunday let's
give them a give him a fair chance
transportation to San Francisco was by
ferry a convivial mode of travel that
particularly in the evening had elements
of fantasy and generated a sense of
adventure that even the beat could enjoy
many of the user a dream secret dream
from the blown spray wet his feet and
his sole sword to the undulation of
these kron4 the Bay Area this is all
early 30s it's put together from a bunch
of different films
that's break on hill cleared for the
bridge approach
for those of you who like scary
construction films you might want to
download bridging San Francisco Bay from
the Internet Archive it's a hair-raising
film about building the bridge a lot
more of this
two-way traffic this is about 1938
[Applause]
it's one of those dudes from every film
there's so much film of the Bay Bridge
this is one of the hardest parts of
putting this together there's far too
much footage of the Bay Bridge
the break was built with a second level
to accommodate the most modern into
urban trains and operation anywhere
control that each end of the bridge by a
tower that houses the switches relays
and circuit but make up the nerve
centers of one of the most efficient fan
control systems and existence but safety
devices that are the product of the
modern modern engineering genius inside
the cab of a conceivable train in
response to the panel which indicates 35
miles an hour at this point this
indicator is part of an elaborate safety
system worked by means of electrical
impulses carried through the rail
if the motorman were to disregard the
speed indicated on the panel control of
the train would be automatically taken
away from him there has never been a
train collision on the bridge since the
big avenues of the 1939
this is 45 the Bell indicates a change
of speed watch closely you'll see the
indicator got 225 miles an hour if he
gets too close to the preceding train he
is automatically stopped and that's nice
to know in a pod yet sometimes peeps in
on the San Francisco side approaching
the terminal for the air is fragrant
with a mallet twice the roasted coffee
the speed drops from 17 to 11 miles an
hour
[Music]
Transbay terminal 1941
it's the Geary Street the beat card at
Geary I believe so we're heading off
market into the South of Market area on
the back of a fire truck this is from a
3d movie but unfortunately we only have
one eye of it
this is sometime around mid-50s beat cop
in South of Market and this is on a
small selection from a lot of footage
that was shot by the Salvation Army in
about 1954 and it's about their work
with you know what they used to call
bombs in the South of Market District
and this is footage of the 4th and
Howard area which is now of course
redeveloped and as is Moscone where you
know people meet to talk about Linux now
but in those days it was a place where
displaced workers itinerant workers
alcoholics and confused people would
hang out and the city for years tried to
get rid of it and finally did but this
is kind of extremely unusual footage of
just street life at that point in time
it's a Greek business if you look into
phone books from that period or actually
a lot of fun of businesses identified
with with with the Greek nationality to
pastry bakery really
that's my recruitment oh yeah record so
these people are marching off for
presumably a meal and a service at
Salvation Army this is Howard around
forth I think
sometime around 38 okay so this is
unedited raw footage of a picket line
from the longshore strike of 1934 which
became the general strike this is after
July 1934 bloody Thursday July 5 when
two workers were murdered and and
there's some references to all this but
this is kind of this is unusual material
I don't know where it comes from
yes some of these films are on the four
up on the Internet Archive for free
download this is I believe not yet
and this is the Embarcadero around the
same time I think now a few years later
and this must be Sunday because it's
it's early in the morning but this is
around 1939 1940 is it great we got to
talk so this is a North Beach looks like
city lights this is posed this was for
the official San Francisco Convention
and Visitor's Bureau film but it's an
outtake as you can see and so is this
and we're on top of Telegraph Hill
sometime in the around then late 50s I
think 56 57 ish so this is the the
Barbary Coast you know what is now we
would call Jackson Square and this is
about 1914 I think and these are sailors
on the towel looking for a good time and
there's a lot of really really
interesting information that you can get
by looking at the signs and looking at
the at the street
so different
there's also a film being shown in there
as well
and now we're in 1932 and this is the
same area that it's all it's it's
derelict
you have to sign on relief bonds
and this is a pan around Portsmouth
Square which of course now is a park in
a garage and this is the old Hall of
Justice coming up which lasted until
when 56 57 ish am i right
Portsmouth Square of course was where
the the city was founded that's where
the first flag was raised
and this is 1939 notice this side that
banner is welcoming people to the
World's Fair
19:41 I think that is that the penguin
project
so where are we do people know Fillmore
hill on the Fillmore Street cable car
this is sometime around 1938 as well
it's when a lot of people started
shooting color film
so this is raw footage I've just kind of
jammed it together shot about 62 ish I
think in its it's just San Francisco
scene from a cable car but it's kind of
beautiful it's vertical like in a way 64
thank you 64 automobile you mean so
right this is edited like like bullet
this is what you look for when you're
looking at how movies you know the
endless flowerbeds and fountains that
don't change very much drive me a little
crazy but this is a lot more exciting
from a dynamic view of the landscape
I think there is that's a wonderful
project for next year
geotag this
this is one of the north of market parts
but I don't know which one Lafayette or
1938 us again
4th Street
19:41 this is our man in the plane again
not pedestrian-friendly
so many of you have seen this film this
is a trip down Market Street considered
to be 1905 but nobody's ever seen it I
think with this quality we have original
material on it and this was copied film
to film and it doesn't jump up and down
anymore it's registered in the level of
detail struck me so much that I wanted
to show it it's really quite amazing
[Applause]
you could do amazing things if you spend
the money in this case actually we did
not but this was paid for by
hewlett-packard in a very complicated
arrangement but when you do film to film
thirty five-millimeter to 35 you can
just get astonishing and they said that
this was what they call the dirty dupe
so they've even felt they could do
better if they had more time
it's said that the the cameraman hired
his friends to do just this to make to
give the film a little more visual
interest give it that edge
see this is life before the nanny
society that regulates every aspect of
behavior
why
don't anybody give away the ending
[Music]
and it's about 1941 again from a
different different shooter I like the
atmosphere here
there is that what it isn't the
streetcar strike yeah looks like fun
Lancia on Saturday night and mid 50s
yeah there's a Giri streetcar coming up
car 10:40 is still around
so it's 1906 just after the quake or
after the fire as some people like to
call it and this is a bunch of footage
we have thirty five-millimeter on it and
it's quite dramatic just because the
quality it actually even gets better but
this is around the corner of Fillmore
and Eddy and it's some people are lined
up for relief other people are just
trying to put things together I don't
have a specific date when this was shot
but that storage company which you're
going to see shortly in another corners
at Eddy and Fillmore
yeah
so I'm sure somebody knows where this is
I don't this is a relief line I think
it's close to City Hall isn't it
there's a lot of footage shot by the
Edison Company in post-quake San
Francisco I personally don't know if
this is this is Edison footage I haven't
done that research yet it comes from a
man named Frank Vail who died a few
years ago at 101 I believe go ahead he'd
actually been alive then but a little
too young to shoot he did shoot the the
panama-pacific in 1915 but he had a
barrel in his basement with some nitrate
film and this was part of it where it
comes from
well the Edison material is quite
well-known in fact some of its on the
Library of Congress American memory site
although the quality does not look so
great and you can compare you know a lot
of the earthquakes footage is surfaced
it's been seen places so I just haven't
done that that hard work yet I was just
struck by this because of the the
quality and amount of the level of the
detail
do we know where this is
it would seem that it was the the
boundary of where explosives were used
you know to build a fire break that
would be one thought City Hall and this
is
19:17 the corner of third and Market
Streets across the street to change
American flag is unfurled a signal that
the United States has declared war on
Germany in the street in their homes the
people of San Francisco celebrate some
of the cheer some shout others courser
week the most of its cheering for
America is glad to be in the fight it
knows little of what awaits the Yankee
go boys over there
san Francisco's manpower joined the
struggle yet Americans are drafted or
volunteer and the first contingent of
citizen soldiers marched down Market
Street the road to the Western Front
company after company block after block
they launched San Francisco's offering
to the First World War
the sound was put on in 1938
but mostly that smiles there the
soldiers of feet of going to make the
world safe for democracy
[Music]
walk the embarcadero the young men of
San Francisco is long khaki clad ranks
so experienced soldiers these are boys
from the office of the factory the
universities the streets from alkyl and
selmak market going off more to a great
game that took bloody war this Bend is
San Francisco 1970 now San Francisco
1918 21 years ago this week the
armistice is signed the war is over into
Market Street for the men and women of
the city to celebrate up and down the
street they parade delirious with joy
for some of them have come to know the
meaning of war is ugly and their
influenza mastering life who is afraid
of the heart signs of hate most of them
just
outpourings of a great joy for this day
November 11th 1918 marks the end of an
era of hate and bloodshed of violence
it's the beginning of peace and goodwill
odor and those who died have not died in
vain they've died to make the world safe
for democracy they've swept the victory
in the war to end war and so
celebrates in 1918 because the war is
over
and there'll never be another so this is
after a VJ Day in August 1945 when there
was a kind of a massive riot on Market
Street as well as a lot of other places
I don't know the source of this footage
it's in part news footage and in part
amateur film and it's quite disorganized
but it gives a sense of the flavor of
the time of the day I was actually I
think three days of of misbehavior worse
than misbehavior assaults rapes knifings
Chrissy field
so this is from the Ransom family home
movies you remember in vertigo he
dresses her up at Ransa Hoffs and they
shot a bunch of things including the
store a trip to the Golden Gate
International Exposition
it's early Sunday morning that's why the
buses have the street to themselves
Essex Street on-ramp and here's there's
the National Cash Register pavilion in
the middle the the numbers showed the
daily attendance at the fair they had
that in New York as well
you see the new bridge in there
anyway the gateway be patient
the art building I just had to show that
and of course this building is still
there
this was the Pan American Airways over
the clipper service
for special service between the United
States and China right there
this is again August 1941
that's called clipper Cove today because
of the Pan Am clipper is not because the
clipper ships
so yeah this is a the construction and
opening of the Twin Peaks tunnel and
around 1917 this is not in order you'll
see that it jumps around but it's such a
rolls a little bit to this Mayor Rolf
was such a dramatic film I've just left
it in the order that I have it marketed
Castro I think
this might be the first car through
okay
err
it's here for the Western neighbourhoods
project
[Applause]
this is Forest Hill station yeah
Yurika Street Station
hardhats were not in use
gun powder
for all you backyard gardeners
so Sunset District somewhere
actor
actors
Naples and Geneva I think
[Music]
looks like Stern Grove from the
background yeah
now the the the box that this roll of
film was in stub it was addressed to
somebody named Solinsky which sounds
like a family that some of us would know
the museum mechanic so I'm curious if
that's that I just got
Diamond Heights
when did the pier come down does anybody
know
[Music]
Playland for those of you don't know
great highway wet balboa to geary there
abouts balboa to fulton excuse me
[Applause]
Sutro Baths this is laid I think they
were abandoned by then this is you know
early 60s
[Applause]
what's that everybody wave
and this is just odd footage from the
early sixties of of art and repertory
theaters in San Francisco sent o-cedar
on Larkin
these particular clips or outtakes from
the official San Francisco Convention
and Visitor's Bureau film and they just
shot a lot of stuff about this is the
bridge I think isn't it and this is
probably what was then in Touhou
this is now is this the Orpheum now my
or the wharf unit or funeral right of
course this is a premier what is this
about 65 66 62 boy I have no film buff
really not
and what the RKO Golden Gate I think
this is more from that 3d film it's
really a film about 3d but we don't have
very much of it
and so now two questions can I make
another announcement too for those of
you who have friends who couldn't make
it or want to see this again we're going
to do this plus some other stuff at
counter pulse at ninth admission on
February 11th so come back for more and
tell your friends who couldn't make it I
just have a couple questions so that we
can head over to the party I know that
was difficult to collect them in the
dark so I guess the first question that
comes to my mind and feel free to pass
them forward if you do have any is where
do you find your found footage um in the
old days I used to have to go after it
and I would talk to producers who'd made
stuff and go to schools and universities
that had switched from film to video but
in recent years really in the last 10-15
years people of people have come to us
and I you know I also have to admit I've
gone back to evil eBay there's some
amazing things here from from eBay as
well though they tend to be overpriced I
don't it's the worst thing that's
happened because people split up
collections and sell them piecemeal and
a lot of integrity is lost but you know
you do it you have to and that's a
another interesting question what we've
always been told it long now is there's
basically there is no economic case for
archives and some of the things that
have started to flip that has been now
with DVDs you get the cutting room floor
now you know Universal is now and other
companies are now realizing that that
those outtakes are somewhat valuable to
them as value-added information but I'm
even more interested as to how you made
the transition from being a a amateur
archivist to a professional archivist
how did that flip in the 80s I just
started collecting so much and ran up
these huge credit card bills
you know renting trucks and things like
that and paying rent on my space in New
York and I somebody explained to me that
I could sell stock footage explain to me
what the public domain was and it was a
natural it was a means to an end and and
so I just kind of monetized it I mean it
was never
we've always been kind of a functional
nonprofit but and in in recent years
there's more interest I mean
interestingly enough after we put stuff
online for free we began to make a lot
more money this is this is scouts honor
it's very interesting and so the people
that come to you for this footage what's
what's the kind of surprising uses that
are the the mundane use that they
usually come to you for and what are the
more surprising usage yeah you know the
mundane use is just use in production
this is what funds us it keeps us alive
it pays for film to tape transfer it
pays the rent that keeps the library
open interesting uses you know I I think
we've only begun to scratch the surface
of what could be done with this material
I'm fascinated with using it for
modeling you know and really trying to
build a world a historical world with
some dimensionality to it that's not you
know kind of faked with 3d animation or
with CGI I mean that can be good but I'm
very interested in how this fits into
kind of a coherent assembly over time
and I think you know gaming people have
just scratched the surface it turns out
a lot of times it's easier to make
something new than it is to figure out
how to use old material but the the
detail and the authenticity of this
stuff really really excites me everybody
says you know people should people use
it in education and to some extent they
do the online archives has used big time
and education but typically a film is
shown to a class you know I think it's
getting people to work with raw material
and thinking about all of this as as as
the basis for new works rather than
completed works in and of themselves
that's I think what gets exciting but I
think an you know ten years they'll be a
lot you know the the paradigms for how
this can be used will be blasted wide
open and brewster what's the access
levels on this footage at the archive
millions of downloads I mean we think
you know like last year was like 20
million downloads and this stuff is
pretty obscure I noticed I happen to see
something online and a Windows Vista
magazine that said we've had one and a
quarter billion downloads of our footage
but I think that was like Vista it was
hype you know but it's in the tens of
millions and you could tell because
there's just a load of derivative works
that are made from this stuff
you know we're people who would never be
able to pay you know are taking the
material and doing stuff with it a lot
of you know students independent
community makers home schoolers love the
old educational films you know
conservative home schoolers because they
because they depict a world that you
know that they look back you know but
not that all home schooling is
conservative but there's all sorts of
uses that we had never anticipated and
this is this is my last question now I
do have to hold everyone in here until I
get the high sign that the lobby is
clear so nobody run away we'll try and
entertain you the the thing that struck
me most in this room and seeing this
this event is that you have all these
people in this room that can help you
metadata this content if you have you
used this kind of crowd crowd-sourced in
the true crowd sense to capture metadata
and there's one person in this one
corner knew more about San Francisco
than I've ever seen Western
neighborhoods project out outside lands
org yeah but so the films that we've put
up online there's room for user
annotation and a lot of that annotation
is incredibly revealing and it's much
more knowledgeable I mean they point out
my mistakes you know and there's I've
copied a lot of those shot lists and a
lot of that explanation from my own
database I think we need to make that
better I think they're working on that
at the Archive right now does anybody
have any other questions while we're
waiting for the lab to clear up over
there
Jeff Alexander Jeff Alexander is an
amazing man he's a connoisseur of what
he calls academic film which are
essentially I was fleeing the line ever
I really should be and um he's
interested in films that were made as
works of art and he's a super smart guy
and a connoisseur and a friend and we've
done a bunch of things together and I
wish he still did shows in San Jose
agency he actually got people into a
basement every week or two to watch
educational films and he and he had
large audiences and he did he's
extremely perceptive program notes but
he's a you know a comrade I would say
there's a lot of you know that's where a
lot of the action is in the arc of a
world is unofficial independent
community practices there's a lot of
innovation coming out of that the home
movie day people are very very good
examples home movie day 30 or 40 places
around the world you should go next
October
but you know I would a lot of times
innovation comes from the periphery and
that's what's happening in the world of
archives I think as I understand it the
lobby is now clear we're gonna keep
doing questions until they taper off
right here yes
how did geotag the essence um I haven't
done it I've read a little bit about
different kinds of research projects
online there are people in this room who
would know a lot more of that about that
in terms of other things you know David
Rumsey in terms of maps and cartographic
files a lot of people have done it on
Flickr there's a lot of geo tagged
material on Flickr and I guess in the
Google photo service as well but I'm you
know I I'm going to be the content
person when it comes to to making these
partnerships happen
what what trends are driving paid
content so we give away footage for free
online and then we're represented by
Getty Images
you know there's a duopoly in the stock
footage industry there's Corbis which is
owned by Bill Gates and there's Getty
Images which was a a public company and
has now been taken private it was bought
by a private equity firm run by Warren
Hellman here in San Francisco and they
charge a lot for material and it's it's
too expensive for some independent
documentary makers we sell a lot to
commercials to feature films to cable
documentaries to corporate in-house I
don't even know you know we seem to make
more money now internationally than we
do domestically but that's because Getty
has offices all over the world I mean
when it comes to selling stock footage I
am a hyper capitalist you know cuz I've
got to keep this operation going but at
the same time we give it away and that
seems to work quite well that really got
a lot more people to know who we were
and what we had and you know the footage
has been online so long now that
somebody who cut something with it as a
student there's now in a position to go
buy it as a professional media producer
and I find that kind of interesting you
know that a web service can become old
green shirt go ahead yep
why not the Golden Gate yeah I got tired
of bridges I mean I started with a Bay
Bridge and yes there's amazing Golden
Gate Bridge footage but most of it is
just people driving around back and
forth on the bridge and some of it is
chillingly beautiful because it's very
empty you know the Golden Gate Bridge I
think was 65 cents when it opened up in
1936 which is a lot of money actually
it's about six dollars now so it's it's
kind of the same that it was now but um
it was expensive then and there was
relatively little traffic I was built to
anticipate the needs of future traffic
and to open up the Redwood Empire so to
speak but I just you know there are a
lot of things I left out please come
back next year I'll try to make it as
different as I can yes there is we have
a little bit the the bridge district has
a lot more we just have a few minutes
and there's a documentary you can go by
at the little um at the gift shop at the
the South Tower
what is the mythical holy grail of
footage the moby-dick of footage my
house in the 30s or 40s um you know I
haven't actually thought much about that
because there's been so many discoveries
like this year we found the color
material of the Golden Gate
International Exposition and I was so
beautiful that I haven't had time to to
kind of want more I'd like to find you
know outside San Francisco there's a
million things I'd like to find but yeah
well thank you this is a next year but
we need to thank long now for getting
the big room I mean that makes such a
difference we clearly should have gotten
a bigger one it's right beyond yep
no I'd love Carville yeah
no footage of Carville I'd what none
none that we know of but you never know
what you'll find
yep yes love to talk to you about that
the question if somebody has a giant box
of old films is Rick interested
do they have Carville okay last question
anyone right here oh you know
interestingly enough in the United
States we have a much although we have a
lot of problems with copyright law being
behind the times we have a great many
moving images in the public domain so
almost all industrial and advertising
films are public domain most educational
films are the question about home movies
is very interesting and I'm gonna level
with you on home movies are unpublished
works and most unpublished works are
under copyright just statutorily but
nobody seems to care
they're orphan works for the most part
and it's one of these things that
although there's potentially a legal
issue nobody has ever done anything
about and I think there's a precedent
that's been set that's much more relaxed
but almost 60% of what we have is public
domain this is one of the things about
the United States that's great that we
we have a public domain the problem is
is that it's not growing it's been cut
off because of restrictive legislation
and copyright intention and extension
and we've got to deal with that but
there's a lot of old stuff we can use I
really appreciate the fact that I mean
most people take the stance of oh well
there's nothing new going in a copyright
why should we even start an archive and
do interesting stuff and the reality is
the majority of history is of course in
the public domain and thank you for
bringing to us thank you
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you